okay welcome everyone to our conference
today as as most of you who are regulars
know over the summer we tend to have our
conferences on a more intermittent basis
but when people with interesting things
to say pass through town we can't pass
up the opportunity to have have them
enlighten us you you and us and and this
conference is also one of the what we're
calling IDL talks the related to the
informatics discovery lab that's a
initiative in the department that's
trying to be more engaging with with the
outside world and so we've invited today
some folks from company called m modal
it turns out actually that ohsu is one
of their clients on the operations side
and we're engaging with them in
conversations more on the academic side
the speaker today is John and Loretta
and are all you guys or you do
everything together that's great okay
well i only have biographical
information on okay he can introduce
them okay and it's it's kind of fun for
me to introduce John because he and I
actually a few years apart I won't say
who's older unfortunately but followed a
kind of somewhat similar path through
life of going to high school in the
northern suburbs of Chicago doing
undergraduate work at the out in the
cornfields at University of Illinois
Champaign Urbana and going to medical
school at University of illinois-chicago
he then went off and did residency
emergency medicine at George Washington
University and then came back to the
Chicago area where he was at
Northwestern University for a number of
years actually started informatics
activities there and then went into the
private set well I guess it wasn't the
private sector initially but it with the
medstar health system and and I'll let
him tell the whole story because I
probably get it wrong but some of you
may be familiar with the Microsoft
product called the zixi that he was
involved with developing well actually
it was developed at medstar then
microsoft acquired it and then John
moved on about a year ago to m modal
where he's the chief medical informatics
officer so I won't mangle his history
any further I'll just turn it over to
him
I think my history is boring so i won't
i won't do any more than what you
already heard other than if that is
Dixie word sounds weird Microsoft
renamed it shortly after we got there to
a mouse or the other word for so I'm
going to talk to you a little bit about
my experiences in what I'm calling
creating magic aspirationally anyway
which is what it feels like when you
have a really really great user
experience in something that you've
created and you know the problem with
with the user experience stuff is that
you talk about everyone your older eyes
or not so obvious common sense and then
you go out in the world and see they'll
be really smart people have created
stuff that appears to be written by
people or designed by people who must
have no common sense because it doesn't
work at all and so what I'm hoping is to
give a set of principles that that we've
followed or identified through many
mistakes along the way we were
apparently just as bad as everybody else
it that designing these things but we
were smart enough to at least learn from
those mistakes trip and falling it back
up and do better and why should you have
to go through tripping and falling in
and you know maybe you can learn from
some of our mistakes and some of the
things that we actually managed to get
right eventually and so I'm going to
talk about some of the principles that
we use to create things that you know
felt like magic to us into some of our
end users when we built them and then
I'm going to turn it over to Lynn kasagi
who is our director of solutions
realization at a modal and Dan angle who
is our team lead in the senior solutions
analyst in their modal talk about how we
actually go about and harvest new ideas
through our lighthouse program so we'll
take the principles and then how do you
then go ahead and apply them in order to
harvest these things and create cool new
things that your your constituents can
use and get value from so with that I
will I'm going to zip through this if I
go too fast or you missed something
please let me know this is northwestern
emergency department this is where I
worked for 10 years I saw patients level
and trauma center we had an increase in
volume as you probably know most
emergency departments are overcrowded we
were in the heart of downtown Chicago we
opened up a new hospital and so we had
you know almost a fifty percent increase
in volume and this is not just you know
people coming in which I have a hangnail
this is these are actual pictures of our
people working in our emergency
departments SuperDuper busy gunshot
wounds and and stab wounds and people in
car accidents and heart attacks and also
I cut my finger and I cut my face and I
got beat up in all this other stuff and
so when we would see a patient we would
have to write up the chart this is
actually a chart I wrote up paper chart
yeah it's hard to read but you know
blame the medical student the medical
speaking of the resident did most of the
work in 1995 this was all I had to write
this is another chart that I wrote up in
the year 2000 every single word on this
chart because of changes in regulations
about who's allowed to document what how
much you have to document every single
word on this chart was written by big
difference and guess what that speech
water so double back right and so what
we found was because we're having all
these increasing patience and all these
increasing requirements about all its
work that I had to do and I had to do
all the documentation I had to do all
the stuff I have to check this box for
this and check this box for that do this
billing code here and do this billing
code there my work required of me was
going way way way up at the same time
that more and more patients were coming
in and the time available to do that
work was going down down now so what I
realized was that time is really a zero
sum game reserve by zero sum game I mean
if you ask me to do some task then i
gotta subtract one I there's no more
time to steal from so if bill says John
I've got a new super new awesome thing
it will really help us down the road in
terms of creating great patient care I
need you to check this box and then
every call is good stuff will happen
well if that checking that box doesn't
save me time then I have to stop doing
something else in order to check bills
box so that means my choice is going to
come down and click your new checkbox
bill or give aspirin to the heart-attack
patient and which one do you think is
going to win and you think I may be
exaggerating but I'm actually not we put
in an EHR at Northwestern this is a
screenshot of the screen that you would
all the stuff you have to enter just to
document one allergy so used to be
you're allergic to penicillin oh don't
go too silly now I have to do all this
stuff just the document penicillin and
so as a result clinicians at our
institution and almost every other one
i've been to have become skeptical of
technology and rightly so this is how it
feels when the chief medical information
officer comes to the hospital and says
to the clinicians we've got some new
technology for you I promise it will be
really good
that that's what they feel like and
they're right so we moved into a no
emergency department in the year 2000
and it was a block long really really
complex a whole bunch of different parts
we did not have any tracking system to
know where our patients were what was
wrong with them or what's going on we
didn't even have a grease port which if
you've ever worked in an emergency
department is like insanity and now try
and do that in an emergency department
that's a block long and while we could
do it in the old one in the new one it
just wasn't working when a patient
called up patients family member called
up and said where's my mom mrs. Smith
literally the nursery the doctor the
Secretary had to go to her wanting are
you mrs. Smith good room two are you
mrs. yep and then go all over the
emergency department blockhawk try and
find out where the heck is mr. Smith so
our nurses said this is insane we can't
function this way we're going to make
our own tracking system and they did
they actually created an Excel
spreadsheet it sort of look like the
shape of our emergency department and
they every single tile patient came in
they erase what was there before and
then we type over the new I know it's &
mrs. Smith with epigastric pain and at
least they solve it I said well okay if
you're going to go do that I mean I
could I could do something better than
that so I wrote a i wrote a tracking
system for our emergency department and
at least a you wouldn't have to erase
everything and we would save it and you
could do all sorts of work on it and I
got a red feed from the registration
system so we could auto populate all
sorts of data so they got all the same
benefit and they did a whole lot less
work and they're really really happy
with it I had the view that was sort of
the geographic view and then this is a
tabular view and the rollout for this
tracking system you've all heard
probably that when you go to roll out a
new system while you need to get
champions and buy and then all this
other stuff my rollout was one minute
so I wrote the tracking system I went
downstairs and I said to the triage
nurse I was working here here's your new
tracking system if you want it I don't
care if you use it click here and this
thing pops up and you can see what the
triage score is click here and you can
change through them okay that's it if
you choose these two go ahead if you
don't use that I really don't care and
that's what ran our emergency department
for the next five years that was a sum
total of our role so I got pretty cocky
wow you know I am amazing I can you know
I can do anything everyone else has all
these problems and I'm just a great
designer that you know I made this great
system so then the sars outbreak
happened how many you guys have heard of
SAR everybody mostly in Toronto and
China but but you know spreading to some
other countries as well the people that
were mostly dying or healthcare givers
right someone would come into the
healthcare environment they infect the
health care giver and then the health
care giver would die so we're being
disproportionately affected I'm in the
heart of downtown Chicago the
Magnificent Mile if you get if you are a
visitor from Chicago to Chicago and you
can imagine plenty of people from Asia
and Toronto in Canada we're coming into
chicago and you get sick you're going to
come back that I mean 95% likelihood if
you're sick in the Chicago area you're
going to come to us if you're in the
downtown area and so our nurses were
completely freaked out we're going to
die you've got to do something and so
they said they wanted a sars screening
tool they wanted a way to check in you
know in my tracking system check for
SARS and so I said no no you're never
going to use it they said yes we will
you don't understand we're the ones at
risk here stop being so selfish you know
you got to make something to help us I
said fine promise you use it they said
yes so I did then I did I did everything
they said you're supposed to do this is
that this is the tracking this is the
thing that you would the screen you'd go
to these fields would be Auto entered
and then you just had to enter the
triage category and location right and
they can enter this stuff if they wanted
to I added this third box on the screen
they were already going through every
single day on every single patient when
they did triage and if you look at that
box it's mice are screening tool the way
I designed it there was only a few
questions to ask in total
and the way I designed it if the patient
the first question was does the patient
have a fever 100.4 if not click no you
don't have to answer any of the other
questions literally a one click start to
the screening and one clip was all you
needed for the majority of the patients
so I followed all the best practices and
all the informatics experts say you're
supposed to do get buy-in I didn't I am
heck they put me in a headlock and
forced me to make the thing get a
champion yes the nurses all were all
over build it right into the workflow
well I absolutely did right on the page
you were using every single day minimal
additional work it was literally one
click and the end users have to benefit
from it which they did supposedly they
were the void stars as a result of it so
now I have a quiz for them it was one
click to screen for SARS on in a week I
went back and looked to see how many
patient visits on how many patient
visits did the triage nurse who is
already on that screen do the one click
to screen for SARS what percent 30-10
0825 okay under that would be excellent
this is the actual graph one percent one
percent of the case okay goals oh now
you might be saying well but John I mean
you know they're not going to it SARS
presents with fever and respiratory
complaints maybe you got so few patients
because you know you're including all
comers right i mean if somebody comes in
with a finger laceration why we wouldn't
expect on the screen for SARS
necessarily so I said fine let's take a
look for the patients who came in where
their chief complaint was a respiratory
complaints so now you really would
actually be worried about SARS what
percent of patients with a respiratory
complaint had that one button check
5 the answer not one not one okay fever
patients the question was does the
patient have a temperature over a
hundred point for a fever for the
patients whose chief complaint was I
have a fever how often did the nurse
check yes the patient has a fever or no
or something's over percentage okay now
you guys are learning not one patient
okay so who did who did we ask about
SARS this is the list not many people on
the list a patient in the car accident
and somebody was beat up by a bouncer
you know we were a few times we actually
asked it it probably wasn't even worth
it to bother yes you know one question
is if the system already knows what the
temperature is why even ask so I I was
hoping somebody might ask that question
and that will be a future part of what
we talked about but we only knew that
there was a complaint to fever and
you're right i could have Auto defaulted
that in there then you're then the next
question would be if I didn't ask they
would then drop down to the next
question and what do you think is the
likelihood they would answer that
question the answer is basically you
know as you've seen it's going to be in
the radio 10 to 1 percent and that's the
main lesson that I learned out of this
thing which was you know how did this
happen right why did I have such a big
success on one thing two big failure on
the other well this is the situation
here right here's the nurse treating
this patient they're doing triage let's
say who benefits when this patient was
breathing stars all over this triage
nurse now who benefits if she documents
that this patient is it's harder
not her too late she's already going to
die right so bottom line is if you're
not the direct beneficiary people aren't
going to do that click and how many
patients in the end actually had some
zero
zero actually ended up having sorry it
turns out that we would have been a
whole lot more appropriately concerned
if we were worried about tuberculosis
meningitis but things that actually do
come into the emergency department not
the thing that's showing up in the
newspaper that day so what I learned is
this and users will not do even one
click not one single extra click if it
does not immediately save them time
every single time they do have so every
single time i have watched an
informatics effort or technology effort
or a process improvement effort goes
straight i watch all the logic about why
people will do it well this is good for
patient care so they will do it how many
people what percentage of the time do
doctors not wash their hands before
going in to see a patient thirty percent
minimum minimum every single study
that's ever been done we've known since
the 1800 that that drops the rate of
death dramatically right if doctors
won't wash their hands caregivers won't
wash their hands before they go in to
see a patient what makes you think
they're going to click your check box
there's your check box can't even
compare to the value you're doing the
patient care compared to washing hands
and you know that's already a losing
proposition so the trick to creating
magic in two words don't fool yourself
that it is anything else and user
experiences
safe
you give somebody something and it saves
time you won't be able to stop them from
doing you give some one thing to
somebody that goes the other direction
even one click in the other direction
and it cost them time you will spend
your whole life beating your head
against the wall complaining about how
nobody is doing this that is if I was
going to give you one lesson for today
you don't have to agree with it but I
obviously well you can pay people to do
things that will cost them time but you
can almost never get the keep that up
right yeah I'm sure I can get bill could
get me to click on that checkbox he
likes me to click if he pays me ten
bucks every single time I click it but
what he's going to do is he's going to
say I'll pay you ten bucks for the first
three months and as soon as the ten
bucks goes away I'm not cooking it
anymore that's what really happens and
that's why sixty percent of projects
fail in the real world they go out there
they put all these people and they
convince you that you should do it and
then you go away and then sixty percent
of the time once you go away and you
take all that extra energy you're
putting into it up back out of the
system again they fall back to their
original state so what is the trick to
saving time again in two words my answer
to that is automate everything so the
rest of everything i'm going to talk
about is how do you automate give this
many examples of engine
first of all there's no point in
automating anything if the automation
itself is going to take so long it's
going to upset so you got a turbocharged
your system nobody it doesn't matter if
the thing will automatically log you in
and automatically do everything for you
if you're just sitting there waiting ten
minutes for the wait cursor that they go
right so that's the number one thing
you've got to get rid of no wait cursors
in fact we've actually known this since
nineteen sixty eight robert j miller
presented at the nineteen sixty eight
ball joint computer conference a study
on what users perceptions are for speed
of response when you click on something
in a computer program so if you have a
speed of response of point less than a
tenth of a second to the to the user it
feels like that was instantly if you go
past a second now the users thoughts
start to drift you start start thinking
about something else ya know what I'm
going to eat for lunch today blah blah
blah blah blah as soon as that happens
as soon as their thoughts go from the
task they're on to something else the
rate of errors skyrockets and there's a
ton of studies about that and then
heaven forbid you ate ten seconds user
will actually turn away from the task
they're doing and go do some other task
while your weight cursor is spinning and
in a significant percentage of the time
as much as ten to thirty percent of the
time they never turn back to the
original past that they were doing that
is how things get forgotten er I was
going to order that aspirin but then I
turned and did something else while I
was waiting for the system to go and
then I forgot before
so this is this is the targets you gotta
set right it's really pretty much one
second you want to make a great system
when somebody clicks on something it
shouldn't take more than a second for it
to respond that's hard to do so how do
you turbocharged it well you mean now
this is getting old you may not get
involved in this but first of all five
better computers and put in faster
networks know whatever wants to do that
guess what business soon the database
right more efficient code and then we
talk a lot about pre-calculated
ingestion so for example this is like a
super secret trick I've done a million
times and it looks afterwards like I
walked in and I was some super genius
but when I tell them what I did then it
then they dismiss it as that was just
too easy I cheated but cheating is great
right if it gets you where you need to
go so let's say that every single time I
show a patient in my electronic record
or whatever system it is that you're
working with I want to show how many
times that patient has been to the top
so one way to do it is to have one entry
in the table for every patient visit and
then John Smith is in here three times
and then a whole bunch more all right in
every single time I go to John Smith the
computer has to go back go through every
single one of the millions of rows in
this table and concept how many gents
miss there are well that's going to take
a long time whereas if at the time I get
a new visit I have a separate table
where I just up the count of it patients
visits then what I just have to go to
this one row and show that now and
suddenly I can literally make something
fifty a hundred or a thousand times back
and why am I telling you this I'm
telling you this not because I expect
you drunk or code and do this stuff tell
you this so that you have this
expectation of the of the folks that you
work with to say it is actually possible
to make systems that will run in less
than a second and these are some of the
ways
and that's just just touching that the
top layer and I just want to you know we
get you so used to things being bad that
we slowed our expectations so far that
then we don't ask for things that really
it should be reasonable right and I want
to up your expectations back up right
when you click it should be instantly
okay how to automate everything another
thing to do that sort of creates magic
is to pre-process everything so this is
the EHR that I had to work with at
Northwestern these are two of the
columns that would pop up in my list of
patients the admitted date and time the
date of birth why do you think they
thought it was important to show the
date and time of the patient's admission
so that I could see how long the patient
has been there so now what do I have to
do now I have to go okay what today is
this date and that was a date that they
came in and I have to do a mental
subtraction in my head to figure out how
long they've been there why do you think
most of the time they put the date of
birth sometimes it's for identification
safe but the real reason hey so now I've
got to figure out let's see if they were
born in nineteen fifty-nine and my math
is really terrible as 2013 now I have no
idea how they're right that's how you
get mistakes that's how you get users to
feel like I don't know I don't can't
explain why I don't like the system but
it feels bad right it turns out that
both of these fields were actually in
and configure ibly in the underlying
system that i have it just wasn't
configured to show it that way by
default so we turned on a system where
actually something good was one minute
away but because we didn't actually
bother to show the pre-processing we
didn't understand what did the user
who's these are going to do with this
data right they were going to do a
calculation for the length of stay well
why not just show it on this day
preprocess that day in show of ready
that's exactly what i do when i made my
tracking system of course so when i said
the room like the Stay I didn't show the
time that they entered the room I showed
how long they've been in the room I
didn't show the time they entered the
emergency department I showed how long
they've been in the emergency department
I didn't show their date of birth i
showed their age I didn't show the date
of their last is that I showed how many
days ago it was I was just
pre-processing a whole lot of data
knowing what would I need to be doing
with that data and how would I use it
by the way my wife wants you to know I
was not she thinks they're going to
think you're an idiot John you kind of
tell know when we go to the next step
when you anticipate the users needs then
they really feel like this thing is
amazing and super magic what is the next
step that they're going to need to do
this is my EHR that I had to work with
at Northwestern here's a patient with a
chief complaint of weakness and when I
pulled up their test results this is
what I saw so now I don't know why I
couldn't calculate the NI in gap all the
informations right there why it's still
pending is beyond me leave that aside
the glucose is 169 and it's a little bit
high so now I want to know what's the
next thing I want to know who this is a
little high okay well maybe is the
patient died back would be cool how
about just is this a normal glucose for
this patient right you know even if they
are a diabetic is 169 good or bad for
them right i'd like to see another
glucose might be related to why the
patient is weak so in order to do that i
actually had to right-click spend the
next three minutes clicking you know to
expand the date range of results a whole
lot further and then all of a sudden I
get all these extra columns and some
extra data here and in order to find out
whether or not there was a prior blue
coat I have to scroll all the way off to
the right and after doing all that work
I have no idea whether or not i will
actually ultimately find the glucose
also by the way now it's elected to show
now that you said you want to see more a
bigger date range now it's elected to
show me that the patients had an MRI of
the brain a nuclear scan of their heart
and a sleep study now for a patient with
weakness do you think something related
to their heart their brain or their
ability to sleep might have something to
do with their weakness
of course right so anticipating my need
the system should have shown me this
right off the bat right and should show
me the glucose right next to one another
so this is that system as Dixie that we
built this is one row per patient visit
and what you can see here is I can see
at a glance the date I really should
have been said of course Calculon we did
this later I should have said how many
days or months or years ago it was but
the date of the last lab that did the
last x-ray the date of the last
radiology reading cat scan MRI angiogram
so I could see at a glance that the
patient did have in fact the lab and how
long ago was and if I double-click on
the lab what he thinks the next step I'm
going to want to do see the left double
click on the x-ray I'm into looking at
the x-ray I'm double click on the MRI am
looking at the MRI but the best part
about this was a blank cell means they
never had an mr i-- don't even have to
go looking for it now i don't have to go
clicking all over the place have they
had an MRI as soon as I see the patient
exists I know if they've had any more if
they haven't had of them right so I'm
actively anticipating their needs this
is that same system now we're looking at
the lab viewer you'll notice that I've
got tabs one for each different type of
lab but next to it is a number right and
that's how many lab tests there's going
to be of that kind of lab so if there's
a zero next to one of these things I
don't have to click on that tab to see
if I'm missing any date in that way I'm
anticipating the users needs i'm showing
you the labs so what is what is the knee
you're probably going to want to look at
the lab you're going to want to make
sure you haven't missed any way though
how do i do that i should i pull forward
do click here don't click there and make
that really easy and obvious here's the
patient's blood glucose by the way
you'll notice this before right the
bedside glucose related
anyway with one double click on that I
can see the lifetime history of the
patient's glucose is one right next one
no scrolling around no digging around
and what's one more click I'm graphing
that over time and I can see that this
patient basically never in close control
so all the glucose is on 300 400 200
range so I already know this patient to
diabetic and a poorly controlled
diabetic attack left knee pain patient
come this is in my tracking system
patient comes in with left knee pain
well what's the first one of the things
I'm going to want to do is the next step
I'm going to want to see their prior
visit they've ever been here before for
knee pain with one click on the last
visit I actually pull up a list of all
their prior visits the first one shows
me arthritis so now I already have some
clue as to why they might have their
knee pain if a patient comes in with a
bleeding court with one now I'm going to
want to know next step what is their
past medical history with one click on
from that very same screen I can jump
into their past diagnosis and I see that
the patients that hemophilia right and
I've actually counted how many times the
patient's gotten each one of their
diagnosis and pre-processed in ordering
so that you see the most common
diagnoses of the most urgent diagnosis
upfront and then everything below that
if I treat the patient I'm in the
emergency department I treat the patient
now I'm going to send them home or I'm
going to admit them to the hospital what
am I going to have to do when that's
called their doctor their private doctor
and say hey this is what happened in the
emergency department i'm going to send
them home now I need you to follow up so
with one click from there I can see
every patient every doctor that the
patient has ever seen according to all
the records that we have now as soon as
I see that the patient seen dr. cater
what do you thinks the next thing I'm
going to do call up dr. Tanner that's
right so with one click I actually
linked into the hospital's directory so
that now I have the phone number right
there by taking it one step further in
the modern world I I'd make one click
and I'd be skyping with them or
something like that
another thing that that you rarely see
done but is incredibly powerful as the
idea of marrying different data types so
if you look at a typical EHR you know
there's one tab for the problems in one
tab for the meds and one town for the
allergies one have for the labs and
never the twain shall write we never put
together the lab test with the relevant
medications or the lab test with the
relevant whatever medical problems but
when you do marry data types like that
that can be SuperDuper useful so bill
and I are on a mailing list called am
this a bunch of CM iOS and stuff and
there was a big discussion what is the
best way to show culture results so
here's a patient with pseudomonas
aeruginosa that the germ growing in
their bloodstream and here's a bunch of
antibiotics that they tested to see what
antibiotic works for that germ s is
sensitive meaning it the antibiotic
works eyes intermediate any me work may
not our is resistant meaning it
definitely doesn't work so then they
want to know what is the best way to
show this to drive the right decision
maker should we show the interpretation
as one letter should we spell out the
whole word of the interpretation should
we emphasize the drugs that work by
capitalizing them or should we emphasize
the drugs that don't work by
capitalizing and this leads to 300
emails
one of which was mine which was
completely ignored and that was hey you
know we suffered with this problem once
and what we realized is most of these
patients are already on an antibiotic by
the time the culture is all comes back
so we really want to do is combine the
medication we know they're already on
already on some antibiotic with the
sensitivity result that tells what
antibiotic works and auto generate some
sort of recommendation about all those
two combined so that's exactly what we
did here you're looking at the organism
is mersa you're looking at the inn tabaq
that was tested oxacillin the
sensitivity is resistant here and the
treating in about the patient not on an
antibiotic site I zoomed it up here and
then I went ahead and said hey problem
knowing about I add together the lab
result with the medication list to
combine and give some summary of what
that means and then to order those in
order of importance so the very first
ones we put up at the top are hey your
patients got an infection and they're
not even on an antibiotic maybe you
should have one the next one is to say
hey you've got a patient who is on an
antibiotic but bad news then I've out
there on the bug is resistant to it it's
not going to work because this is the
antibiotic they're on vancomycin and
this is the sensitivity of income I
sandwiches visit right and so by putting
those two things together it's much more
powerful than deciding should I
capitalize it or not it's just saying
what should I do keep going with the
antibiotic switch them or add an
antibiotic because there's not one there
this is something that a guy named dr.
Michael hochstein did in the surgical
ICU he created a in our system a device
tracker every single central line in
chest tube and every single holy
catheter and a tracheal tube but every
tube or line that was in the patient's
body he would track it here and then he
combined what he knew about the device
that's in the body with the culture
results so that if you have a central
line sitting in your bloodstream and you
have a blood infection you got a problem
either the central line is causing the
blood infection
Casey got a poem or the blood infection
is going to infect that central line so
you gotta pull that's what you bottom
line is we combine two different data
types together in order to create some
sort of obvious experience or instead of
making the doctor go ahead and say well
here's the line now let's compare the
culture now try and adjudicated to my
head we combine those natively and you
get this super magical field changing
modality gets pretty cool used to have
to document on keyboard but this is this
is our product of m modal where we
document by voice and someone signed a
woman and no keep the stress with a
history of coronary artery disease
common type 2 diabetes coming as my
comma and hypertension I tag on the
ultimate eight years coma when I
completely ground swap m1 and
complaining of a sore throat and
swelling of the tongue courage came
immediately to the emergency department
because she was having difficulties
falling in some trouble breathing due to
obstruction caused by the swelling
period she has never had the similar
reaction ever before and she did not
have an innocent way better way Chad
Allen catching up compared to typing it
out we have a ton of people who think
they're much faster at typing than
speaking until you actually run them
head-to-head and then you find out it's
not it guys are all probably familiar
with Siri now and voice and voice out
interfaces but 12 years before that we
actually thought changing from voice to
visual changing from visual i should say
you know what you see on the screen to
voice and voice out we thought would be
pretty cool so to prove that i actually
beat theory on this by 10 years you can
see that I'm a lot younger in this video
no gray hair nor Cali yes John tell me
about room three please okay John Smith
is the 45 year-old male in room three he
has been here 12 times the last being
eight days ago at that time with a
complaint of stomachache and today is
here with a complaint of
no pain triage category read request
completed we saw I had a tracking system
that i wrote right so I actually tied
that into the tracking system i'm going
to skip the next video i actually put
this thing on my head because we didn't
have mobile phones at the time i
actually put that thing on my head and I
walked around the emergency department
treating patients and talking to my
computer with this contraption on my
head and the residents and the other
doctors and the patients thought I was
crazy but it totally worked it was
really cool and I wish I had a picture
of me wearing it like that but I don't
but actually now bringing it forward to
the modern day we do have modern devices
with voice and voice out capability and
so now we can actually be totally mobile
and this is a product that we're doing
in partnership with Intermountain that
allows us to do voice-based order entry
of medication so here we are looking at
the app let's say that I'm out and about
I'm in my car I'm a physician I'm in my
car i'm walking the halls of the
hospital suddenly i get a call there's a
patient who has some just had a
procedure patient has some mild pain
they want to order maybe some tylenol or
some Advil or something like that
so normally i could do a verbal order
and then hope they don't miss transcribe
it I could hope that they don't I can
hope that or they I can wait till I get
to a computer and hope I don't forget to
do it or I can just plop my phone or my
iPad Mini and I can do the order by
voice in this way so I have a list of my
patients I can select the patient in the
future will probably offer the ability
to you know select the patient by voice
but I'll say ok there's a bit blue I'm
gonna I just hit the record button
tylenol 650 milligrams p oq' four to six
hours PRN pain or fever
Meredith perfect recognition it got
tylenol but you'll notice that it
converted it to acetaminophen head it's
10 times later in the video I actually
do it by hand and you see even for a
simple touch screen interface that I
could do five three to five orders by
hand come by voice compared to how often
how quickly I can do it bye bye voice we
actually have done some things that
didn't work we tried modality change
saying hey instead of doing reality what
if we had a virtual reality sort of an
environment so this was believe me
state-of-the-art back in two thousand
401 did this how many of you have ever
heard of the video game quite the
original quake engine not quite two or
quite free we may we use the original
video game engine of quake to make a
video game based electronic health
record and this is this is that record
you could literally fly around the
emergency department this is a real-time
view of what the emergency department
look like inside these are patients in
each one of these things and there's
little icons over their head you could
fly into a room and if you saw x-ray or
mad or or past medical history you can
click on the icon and and the x-ray
would show and it turned out that was
actually cool but not that useful it was
just a lot of extra navigation for no
real benefit but the good news is is
when you try something crazy like that
you do learn and find out where would
this thing be useful so one of the
things we did was a modality change with
them even before connect happen so
actually um we did this years before
connect you guys are familiar to connect
on the Xbox gesture recognition and
stuff they actually at Microsoft stole I
developer to work on the connector
but we said hey what happens when you're
bound and gloved and sterile in the
operating room and now I need to look at
the cat scan or the MRI to see what
what's going on and we said maybe
gesture recognition would be good for
that but manipulating an EHR that's used
that was designed by mouse isn't really
good for that so we actually did was we
put the x-rays into a virtual reality
environment and then used your hand to
manipulate that virtual reality
environment and it worked really really
great so even when we've made mistakes
and things a failed we learn from that
and apply them in new and different ways
this is actually a real patient there's
real patients somewhere in there where
her head is actually open in the best
neurosurgeon was digging around for
trying to find where those tumors are
those big white spots in the brain and
he needed to stop and go look if he was
testing our thing out see all those
other people there it's a little hard to
see there's a whole bunch of other
people that you know who they are all
the other surgeons from all the other
operating arms left their patients open
on the table and came in there to see
this because it was so cool so and that
really really really did feel like magic
how else to automate everything you can
reassign the work it feels like magic if
you don't do it and somebody else does
the work for you oh here's one where we
have transcriptionists do the work this
is a thing we have called fluency flex
where you can dictate and speech
recognizer it it will automatically
create all the text for you but then you
have to go through and you have to
correct it if it has made any mistakes
what if you don't want to correct it you
don't want to make you know there's
mistakes in there but you don't want to
correct the mistakes that happen the
speech recognition this little tiny
magical button right here where the
arrow it says send to the transcription
if you click it goes to the
transcription is still correct it for
you send it back into your EHR feels
like magic because yes human did it but
it wasn't use of who cares right really
really great similarly let's put our
patients to work and say well you know
it feels like magic to me if all the
medications and allergies are already in
the record and I wasn't the one who had
to enter them so here's an example I'm
not affiliated with these guys but of a
website where patients can go they can
enter their allergies their medications
their prior problems the review of
systems and it automatically uploads
them to the electronic health record and
then the clinician
and the actual visit can affirm confirm
or deny each of these things and when
the patient does it it feels like magic
because the main thing is it saves me
time I don't have to do that one utilize
ambience so this is like what we have at
the airport where you don't have to log
in or do anything the the displays about
when your flight is leaving if it's late
or not I just sort of there on the walls
and you can just see them so we've done
the same thing with stuff like
contaminated culture reduction so when
when you get a blood culture if you
don't clean the area well enough then
that looks like there's an infection but
it's really just because you've got
stuff from the skin on there it means
the phlebotomist to the nurse or the
doctor did a bad job in cleaning it's
responsible for a lot of money and a lot
of extra days spent in the hospital so
we put up a graph of each phlebotomist
and how many contaminated cultures they
had in their work and guess what nothing
else it all got better right everyone
could see that this guy right here was
the worst lobotomist in terms of that
problem and we didn't have to do
anything more than just put the data up
on the wall and show it every single day
and it just went better all by itself
the Hawthorne effect same thing with
self-pay over 65 no patient really in
the United States and once they're from
out of the country or something should
be self-pay over 65 because we have a
thing in this country called Medicare
right and most of the time when it's a
self pay over 65 what that means is the
registration clerk didn't do their job
right they should have they just said
self pay instead of asking the patient
if you have Medicare can have your
Medicare number it's bad for the patient
because then they get a bill for a lot
of money and it's been for us because
they never pay that bill so what we did
was we put the name of the registration
clerk in every single patient that was
self paying we just put that up on the
wall where the registration pricks work
and guess what that thing just went
right because nobody wants to be there
knowing that everyone can see they're
not doing their job this is an orb that
I tied to the how busy the emergency
department was in my tracking system i
actually had it in my house it would be
blue if there was you know not a lot of
people yellow if there was a lot of
people and red if it got really bad and
literally one day i'm working the
emergency department and you know there
was some huge accident a school bus you
know and the ton of people came in and
my wife calls me up one second later
goes everything okay your orb just
turned red
that's magic right no work whatsoever
and everyone can just see what's going
and then this is ambient display as well
I'm documenting and we use natural
language processing to see that you're
talking about congestive heart failure
but you haven't documented it correctly
an FYI that you know hey by the way you
stopped out you know lasix 10 days ago
maybe that has part of the problem and
you used CC which jae-joong Commission
says is a dangerous abbreviation maybe
you should use milliliters automatically
pull the medical history from the
records that we already have and show
that for for contact so these are
ambient displays that just shown
uninterruptedly to help me do a better
job without doing any real extra work
and then finally the ultimate is auto
populated data nobody wants entering a
log in a password so we put an Irish
scanner that and we thought finding down
still too hard so we created facial
recognition software here you can
actually see somebody sit down and
they don't type it system just starts
logging them in
next guy is even faster he sits down
he's going to type in his ID but it's
already logged a minute he's super happy
right to him this is this is as magic as
magic gets tracking board instead of
having the nurses enter the patients in
room 1 now the patients in room 3 now we
actually put RFID tags on the patient
and then we can actually follow the
patients as they go from room to room so
now nobody have to enter that data BMI
so if you want to do a body mass index
which is the sign of an important thing
for your health you need the height and
the weight so we put a scale on the
floor and as you walk in we
automatically captured your weight but
what about the height so we actually put
an ultrasonic transducer up on the
ceiling and when you walked under the
ultrasonic transducer would measure the
distance and calculate your height you
can see me actually gaming and then we
ought to enter that into the into the
system and then finally the ultimate is
auto-populated documentation and where
we already know stuff that's in the
record so we'll just use that to auto
populate what's already there that you
have shortness of breath that we think
it might be due to the lasix that we
already know is new was stopped a few
days ago auto import the vitals from the
nurse and I don't generate honest that's
when a plan and I can delete this if
it's not right but you know then
everything feels like magic that's what
we're altima tlie hoping you get so
we've talked about creating magic save
time by automating everything in
automating everything by turbo charging
your systems pre processing the content
anticipating the needs wearing datatypes
change all these thing and those are the
high level things now i would put
together a video for video of the future
and my my how i think this all comes
together but i'm not going to do that
why because i want you guys to go and
invent the future i've given you the
principles on how to do it go out there
and make something cool and don't listen
to some old fuddy-duddy like me tell you
i what to do go do something cool for
yourself and along those lines i want to
introduce lynn and dan are going to talk
to you about how they take these
principles and then find new ideas and
harvest them in in in a really tangible
ways in order to create new and cool
thing
yes
can you hear me okay great my name is
Lynn koseki I'm the director of
solutions realization for m modal my
team and I are the ones who go out and
work with folks like you with our
provider partners folks like Dan they
follow doctors around they follow h.i.m
personnel around and we document
workflows we try to find the pain points
we try to figure out how can we help
each other how can we can we work
together so we have a program at m modal
that we called the lighthouse program so
use your imagination so a lot of people
will say they'll look at this picture
and they'll say well why are you looking
down into the fiery depths of hell if
it's supposed to be a good thing so no
you have to turn your eyes around you're
looking up at the light in a lighthouse
and the reason we call it this program
this program the lighthouse program is
because we work with a handful of select
health care providers organizations such
as yourselves here and because these are
the folks who are already a couple of
years out ahead of the rest of the
industry these are the folks that are
already facing the challenges so these
are the people that working with them we
hope to be able to kind of light the
path for the rest of health care hokie
as it may sound but it's fun so so dr.
handler was just talking a little bit
ago about some documentation challenges
so in health care today what do doctors
and healthcare organizations get paid to
do anybody what do they get paid to do
to document oh gosh usually people don't
fall for that so they don't get paid to
see patients and they don't get paid to
care for patients they get paid to
document because if it's not documented
it wasn't done and if it's not
documented well and if it's not
documented accurately then no one has
the correct picture of what's actually
going on with the individual patients
and what's actually going on with the
entire population and right now
particularly is we're moving towards
value based healthcare value-based
reimbursement this is more and more
important that we have an idea of the
actual health of the population so that
the health care is reimbursed adequately
so torn
that end somebody somewhere along the
line decided that the best way to
document for patient care is in
structured data so that we can reuse
that data downstream for lots of
different purposes and that makes
absolute sense unfortunately they also
decided that the best way to capture
this information discreetly such that it
can be understood by computer systems
down stream it can be analyzed and
reused is to create a whole bunch of
checkboxes and structured text fields
and to force doctors to spend a whole
lot of time pointing and clicking point
in clicking pointing and clicking so
this is the type of thing that we hear
from h.i.m professionals and the
organizations where we go we hear that
the notes are redundant because
physicians in an attempt to save time
are doing lots and lots of copying and
pasting and oftentimes the information
is redundant sometimes even incorrect
causes lots of problems the residents
are text messaging so some of the
younger doctors coming into the health
systems are our custom to I aming their
customs text messaging they're making up
their own abbreviations so we all know
there's the the Joint Commission is out
there and they have a list of do not use
abbreviations that's an old-school list
that was created back in the days of
hand written documentation and they came
up with this list of do not use
abbreviations because they're the ones
that if written in handwriting could be
misconstrued misinterpreted to be
something else they're really dangerous
abbreviations that are being used right
now are the ones that that doctors in an
attempt to save time are making up on
the fly everybody knows about the Joint
Commission do not use lists everybody
knows what they are but you don't know
we've seen some some incidents and Den's
going to talk about this later where
doctors are actually creating doing this
n slash of these / whatever / whatever /
whatever up to eight characters long and
then someone else is supposed to know
what that means so the doctors won't use
it documentation modules in the EHR even
in places where the other modules of the
EHR well adopted documentation the
documentation modules are
very poorly adopted the doctors that we
talked to say I can't see the patient's
story I've got all this information at
my fingertips but I can't actually see
what's going on with the patient they
say I can't tell what's new I can't tell
what's changed between yesterday and
today they tell us I can't tell how the
patient feels I've got all their vitals
I've got all their labs but there's
nothing in that electronic health record
that tells me how that patient feels
today compared to how they felt
yesterday I see two fewer patients every
day now because it takes me too long to
document or they say they save all of
their documentation for when they go
home or on the weekend because they just
don't have time to do it take so long so
and this one I'm undercoating and I'm
under billing because of the way that
they're capturing information they're
not necessarily sure that they're
capturing it correctly and because
they're afraid of audits they're afraid
of being caught over coding and over
billing they're actually a lot of them
that we here are purposely undercoating
an under billing this can mean a big
loss in revenue for any healthcare
system and unfortunately we'd all like
to say that we're all here to keep
people well but healthcare doesn't
happen without money so that's a pretty
important one so our lighthouse program
why do we do it to inspire innovation at
a modal we have lots and lots of ideas
lots and lots of smart people but we're
really going to learn which ideas are
very useful we're really going to source
these ideas is through these healthcare
provider partners it teaches us how to
better serve health care and most
importantly hopefully we can create the
tools to help to bring other healthcare
institutions the smaller community
hospitals into the realm of the
lighthouse type providers so who is the
lighthouse so it's a limited number of
customers that we work with and we
actually co-develop with right now and
includes the Mayo Clinic geisinger
Health System in Pennsylvania university
of california irvine we were just up at
Beth Israel Deaconess last week talking
to them about some challenges I'm just
going to talk a little bit about some of
the
things that we've heard from a couple of
these partners and how do we kind of get
started how do we figure out what we
want to work on together how do we
figure on what's a benefit what's of
value to healthcare providers so this is
one of my very favorite statements that
I've ever come across and this is from a
dr. Kenwood he's the chief medical
officer at the geisinger medical center
the geisinger Health System end up in
Danville Pennsylvania and he says
documentation is the process by which we
crystallize what's going on with the
patient so the first time we met with
him in his office he's ex-marine right
so he's got the shiniest sparkling lyst
office you ever saw so you're kind of
afraid to touch anything because you
might smudge right so but he's got this
big bank of metal file cabinets because
even though he's fully electronic he
uses they use epic there he's fully
adopted he's pretty convinced that
someday when something happens and all
connectivity shut down and all the
electricity is gone gosh darn he's got
his paper so but it's pretty funny
because he walked over to a file cabinet
one of these drawers one day and the
drawer was actually labeled very very
beautifully stuff so he opened his stuff
drawer and he pulled out some examples
of documentation and he showed us what
he considers to be useful documentation
now this is copies of paper and this is
the way he documents and because he's
ex-marine his documentation is perfect
right so what he would have what he
would have at the top of every paper is
a diagram and he would start with the
principal diagnosis he worked in the he
was ahead of the ICU and then he would
break it down into the ancillary
diagnosis the contributing factors so
that anyone who picked up that patient's
chart could get a really quick snapshot
a really quick picture of what's going
on with that patient and then underneath
that and very neat military script he
also spelled out more information in
narrative about all of those conditions
about what was going on with the patient
dr. wood was unique
you saw dr. handlers documentation
earlier not quite so neat most of the
most of the doctors I've run across
their handwriting looks a little more
like dr. handlers dr. Woods actually the
only one I've ever seen that looked like
dr. Woods but his point is though that
an EHR is set up in a very linear
process if you want to see labs you
click here if you want to see allergies
you click here it's one two three
doctors think in parallel they think of
all of these things at the same time so
that they can understand so that they
can initiate that their thought process
initiate the care process about these
patients dr. wood says that the way
doctors used to document they actually
use the documentation process to
crystallize what's going on with that
patient now they're forced to conform to
a template so now their thought
processes are forced to conform to the
EHR and not the other way around dr.
Woods challenge helped me to create a
system that I can use for documentation
that helps me to crystallize what's
going on with the patient that correctly
captures and he used this phrase the
exquisite care that we provide to our
patients and which helps my doctors to
do it quickly and efficiently easy right
problem solved not so much okay so this
is out at Mayo Clinic and this is in
Rochester Minnesota and we worked there
and we've been working with them for a
couple of years now they still have
in-house transcriptionists a lot of
transcription going on there they have
the best partnership between medical
transcription and electronic health
record and physicians that I have ever
seen anywhere bar none so Mayo has one
of the original CDA based clinical
document architecture based systems else
is out there so they're capturing all
the information electronically their
physicians dictate and their medical
transcriptionists have to turn that
information around really really quickly
because very much like your a facility
Mayo Clinic is a destination health care
a lot of the patients come from
elsewhere they're staying there for a
couple of days so they're seeing a
number of specialists in the course of
the day and based on what that first
doctor says they may have another
appointment in four hours they may have
another appointment in 45 minutes so
that documentation has to be turned
around like that so those
transcriptionists really have to be up
there but what those transcriptionists
are also doing besides just creating a
document is because they're working in
the CDA based editor as they edit the
speech recognizer content that we
produce they're actually validating the
electronic structure of that
documentation so that they don't know
they are but but they are because of the
way the system set up they're actually
helping the doctor to reconcile the
patient problem list the allergies the
medications and they've been doing this
for 15 years long before Meaningful Use
was even a Gleeman dr. John holem goes I
so so that was something that we learned
there is that sometimes there are things
going on and the user doesn't even know
what they're doing but they're actually
doing something very important what our
team does then and what all of you
should do if you're looking for
solutions to problems is a lot of times
folks think oh okay so to find a problem
and to find how to solve it listen to
the people listen to listen to what the
problems are listen to why they don't
use it we turn around and we say no
let's talk to the people who are making
it work let's figure out where they're
using sticky notes and duct tape to hold
things together so that we can automate
that sticky notes and duct tape and
figure out how to how to fill those gaps
so our methods we create very high touch
relationships with our provider partners
so that we can kind of create the
champions to create adoption to create a
bond that survives challenges when
you're working with new software the
first iterations of it it's going to
suck it always does right but you've got
to start somewhere we believe in putting
something out
asked getting it out in front of users
getting feedback on it if it's going to
fail we want it to fail fast so we can
iterate get the next version out collect
more feedback until you get something
useful otherwise you can sit and if you
go through a more traditional method
collect requirements collect
requirements collect requirements you
can still be collecting requirements
somebody has been through this so you
can be collecting requirements for the
next two years and never come out with
anything it's actually useful so we work
together with our partners to observe
what's going on to hypothesize about
what a solution might be to experiment
to fail and fail fast to iterate do it
all over again until you actually come
up with something useful so and that's
our team right there let's stand in the
orange he's going to kill me later for
saying that so so now those you I'm not
in there okay so and now I'm going to
actually hand it over to Dan Dan is my
team lead on my team and he's just going
to tell you about a day in the life of a
solutions analyst this is how we work so
I think we have a couple minutes left
they'll go quickly through this not
super interesting so we can have
questions and discussion but like Lynn
said we do a high-touch relationship we
do workflow observations we document
look for the sticky notes and duct tape
and work with the people who are making
things work even though they're not
great and they suck and they also we
compare that to the ones who are
complaining not using it the grants
slides here so while this is a fun you
know meet and greet and get to know each
other visit this is a day at guys near
hospital which was kind of a crazy day
where I had to wear a lot of hats and
work on a lot of different projects all
at once so this is kind of typical for a
visit we're going actually getting
really deep into these projects and
understanding so the day started early
with a meeting with a steering committee
for these projects over all that we're
calling closed loop documentation where
we're doing some of the things that dr.
handler spoke about automating tasks and
bringing data out of the Buried EHR to
bring it to a point of care to help
improve
communication processes make it more
efficient and work smart where we can so
this was this the overall steering
committee we had to do some
demonstrations report on progress easy
start to the day actually I'll probably
hardest part today so we the rest of the
morning was spent observing rounds this
was probably my favorite part of the day
because I really enjoy watching patient
care i like seeing how the people use
their systems and i'll share one really
interesting observation this group of
residents I shadowed were going around
and they were in the ICU one patient
they spoke to was in pretty critical
care he was very unaware of where he was
he to know the president was and instead
of looking up in the record who his
cardiologist was and when his heart
surgery was they asked this confused
patient i asked the resident later why
did you ask him why don't you just look
it up and because there was a chance
that this confused patient would
remember it and it was easier than
finding in the system not just kind of
forking i was very surprised by that so
i was interesting we take I take a lot
of notes I think later there's an
example of a workflow diagram and you'll
see this is what the person in charge of
the department will say is the process
this is what actually happens is what's
supposed to happen so that's the fun
part a lunch if we have time and then I
did some shadowing there are some
doctors that were using some of our
speech software that dr. handler
download before and I got to do some
observation to sit be a fly in the room
while they document look for gaps in
that process understand where we can use
voice commands and replacement rules to
make things easier streamline the
documentation process make it as
seamless as possible for them we also
use that to build more work flow
diagrams understand when they document
where they document what information do
they need at point of care that we would
use you know text mining you want to
pull out of the system for so it all
comes together I also met with the chief
of radiology who's a champion for our
catalyst projects which is our natural
language processing and text mining
application so we're working with him
I'll show another slide later trying to
identify who their real triple-a
abdominal aortic aneurysm patients are
according to their billing codes and the
structured data in EMR they have I think
around a thousand and throughout this
project we found by mining the narrative
that they have almost two to three
thousand patients with triple-a
so we're able to find that real
population and we want to even take it a
step further to try to bring that
recognition of an a triple a patient by
the narrative to the point of care and
ask the radiologist could you please
initiate follow up or make sure that
this ends up on the right list so that
we can follow up with those patients
later last but not least the clinical
innovations team is I had a meeting with
them and they're the ones who actually
we work closest with and that set us up
with the radiologists and the physicians
using her speech software and the
governance committees though the ones
that are the foot in the door to help
coordinate these activities so that was
a mostly planning session adjusting the
day and then last but not least I have
to you know finish up my work do some
diagramming get my notes out of my paper
notebook so I don't forget it or I'll
never do it again and eventually it's
time for a dinner a beer because there's
another day usually these trips for two
or three days so there's a nice little
brew pub in danville PA quaint little
town if you're ever in rural
Pennsylvania I think there's some
examples and finish up so we have
questions oh no not example then we can
talk about that later so this top
picture is what's supposed to happen
that's the full detailed process for
problem lyst management to trigger
appropriate risk levels for patients
that they're in the right risk profiles
and get reimbursed the right levels for
them the bottom left is the simple part
of it what's supposed to happen they're
supposed to update their encounter list
so that it triggers the right claim and
they get the right risk adjustment level
and they're also supposed to update the
problem list to trigger their care gap
management program initiate some of
these clothes with documentation
processes but what really happens is
they update the encounter list with a
nun specific condition so that it
doesn't get the right risk capture and
then they don't go to the problem is
because it's extra clicks and they
already updated one list of an arc and
update a second list and then they end
up you know with poor risk levels that
doesn't trigger their care gap
management program and so we're looking
how we can mine old data to update the
problem with make sure it's reconciled
make sure it has the most specific
conditions
this is examples of what we did with the
triple a project again we mind the
narrative of reports to find all the
incidental findings from radiology
studies not just the ones that had a
billing code of abdominal aortic
aneurysm and then we also risk
stratified them by understanding what is
the size of that aneurysm so here's all
your aneurysm patients or 3,000 you
thought you only had 1500 but also these
are the ones that have aneurysms that
are greater than five centimeters they
probably should have seen vascular
surgery a month ago and this is an
example a screenshot of what our system
looks like it's the identified but this
is where we could see where we're
identifying in the narrative that this
was an aneurysm and it measured five
centimeters in maximal diameter last
Lynn mentioned the dangerous radiation
project this is again something that
guys near spends a lot of time manually
reviewing documentation looking for
presence of these abbreviations because
if they find it before the doing
Commission does they can correct the
action with the doctors and notify their
departments if the Joint Commission
finds that they're going to slap him on
the wrist and take money away from them
so we found out though that this manual
review process took about 30 hours a
month so review five to ten percent of
their documentation so we did a
side-by-side comparison using our
software and we tried to we improve that
process down to about five to eight
hours and now we're working on scaling
it up to do more than ten percent review
yeah so Jung Hwan rocks a given you the
you've given you the principles on which
to create magic you've given you the
workflow on how to actually go out and
harvest new ideas for creating magic and
so this is an awesome world-famous
informatics centre so I'm looking
forward to seeing you guys go out and do
it and hopefully send us a note about
something cool that you've done thanks
so much
and let me just ask for those who don't
know if when you talk to push like I'm
pushing on the button here mostly so it
will be recorded on the video tape so
the people that are listening and
hearing it since I'm pushing the button
I will ask first question a lot of these
interface things are really cool and you
know they you know all the principles
kind of resonate with me we sort of have
this problem in health IT it's it's a
generic may be epic kind of problem in
terms of implementing these sorts of
things I think you know what I'm getting
at IX I should explain for those who
don't know there is a system that has a
large share of the market place called
epic that's a very kind of closed system
in terms of its interface how did you
work with epic customers and if so how
are you able to kind of get into the
guts of things to be able to implement
some of these obviously efficient things
you did say to do that too so 11 knots
place or interface so so we kind of
attack it on on two levels so we do have
conversations going with epic all the
time and they're very interested in
working with us but because they're
they're pretty busy these days because
of Meaningful Use and other things that
are going on so in order to get some of
our work with them prioritized more
highly on their list of things to do
more pressure on them from their
customers is always key so we have some
key provider partners who are epic
customers and who are kind of asking
epic hey we want you to integrate more
closely with m modal so but we also have
to assume that even if epic says yes
there's a whole lot of other EHRs that
may not or they
may not yet and also even if they say
yes today it's going to take time to
actually get it out there so we also
have need to make sure that there's a
number of things that we can do kind of
on top and beside it without necessarily
having to have a deep integration so
yeah I agree we've got we've got a lot
of integration with epic I you know some
of our best integrations are are done
with epic and there's some things that
we want to be able to do that can't do
it that you know I can't put this thing
in there right I don't own that or
control that code so then the question
is what what are my options my option
number one is I'll put my own window up
there which actually showed an example
of that our product that's coming out
soon called i think in next month or so
called echo well codename echo we don't
actually coming out a month we don't
have an a before it yet but but I should
you know the the ambient window that is
just sort of showing and as you type or
you speak we're recognizing the natural
and understanding the natural language
that you spoke or typed and then we're
actually pointing up information that
might be of use to you because this is
what you said well they don't have a
place for me to put that right now so we
created our own window and and float
that over I think for all these sorts of
things you've got two paths one path is
to find a workaround and the other path
is to try and make an appt three pass
try and make it happen but there is a
third path and the third path is to say
you know there's a million problems in
the world to solve and if this one
proves to just be way too hard to take
one of those two paths I'll just not
solve that problem and I'll pick a
different one instead and i think the
the the key to the success that I've
seen has been not getting married to the
problem there's enough problems that you
don't have to pick one and get married
too
instead say what assets do I have what
things can I do relatively
straightforward fashion and what
problems of the million problems that
exist in the world problems can i solve
with the assets that i have and that
that has made all the difference really
in the world in terms of where we found
success there's a million things we
wanted to do that we're just impossible
and yet when i show the things we did do
they look like that was amazing and why
because we could we could do those and
there i'm not i'm not talking about the
ones the other 800,000 problems we
couldn't sell yes
I'm informatics to India my questions
regarding the Czar's example that we
said tank temperature 100 should be
recorded why sometimes we can have that
as a trigger right something which has
to be mandatorily filled in before you
can proceed further with the workflow my
question is like what's a maximum limit
of those mandatory fields that we can
have for encounter before the fatigue
sets in like um one you know it's so
easy to get carried away with these you
can't proceed to the next thing until
it's mandatory you put one of those
things in there and your your users will
be pulling their hair out going in this
is why I liked paper because that didn't
exist for paper and I think the key
questions that come to my mind are why
you know question number one is do I
even have to make the doctor capture
this is it already existing somewhere
else and I simply am failing to reuse
the information that's already there is
there somebody else that could do this
work besides this one person that's like
super overworked already is there some
way that I can infer this or capture
this automatically if I can't do that
then my next question is how important
is this thing really because you it's
not there is an opportunity cost for
every single thing for somebody to do
and it's easy to just imagine that you
know that time is this infinitely
expensable thing but it's not and so you
know the minute that you if their
natural reaction you're putting in a
mandatory thing because their natural
behavior is not to do the thing that you
want them to do right they think there's
something more important that they
should be doing so you can put in an
infinite number of mandatory things as
long as for every one of those things
you put in you take one or two other
things out that then balances out their
time appropriately you want me to spend
the next ten minutes doing nothing but
filling out a form I will happily do it
as long as you take ten minutes Oh or
better yet 15 minutes away from other
activities that I would otherwise
have to do so that I perceive this thing
as in that time savings and so my answer
to you is is to look at the entire
process and say I need to come out net
zero at least preferably net you know-
in terms of time net net good in terms
of time savings and you can look at all
the processes they have and say I'm
going to make this thing you know five
minutes worse but in return I'm going to
make this thing 10 minutes better not
this thing next week 10 minutes better
this thing right now and when you do
that you can get away with a whole lot
more so my answer to you would be you
know the least possible preferably 0 and
if you feel like you have to put them in
there then you should feel the same onus
and the same responsibility to take
something else out the mere fact you're
making it mandatory means the user has
already decided that they have other
activities that they think are more
important than your activity so you got
to figure out a way your honor
you had a few principles that I found
interesting one was anticipating the
users need and the other was showing
data and aggregate but sometimes you
might not be able to anticipate the
user's name so my question is have you
thought about developing interfaces that
allow users to create their own
presentation of the data yes at the so
I'm you know no but you're starting me
on one of my favorite topics at my last
position we created we created this
thing that was built all around that and
entirely around that as an idea that
probably ninety to ninety-five percent
of users won't ever create anything
whatever you stick in front of them
they'll either complainer they'll do it
or they'll find a workaround but what
they're not going to go invent something
however everywhere you look in in every
facet of life there is the five to ten
percent of people that I call the
activists they can't stand anything not
being you know optimized and nothing in
the world will stop them from trying to
make it better right and so those are
the people you don't know who they are
you know where they are but every single
Department had knows who they are
they're the person that sort of making
your life miserable all the time
constantly complaining or thinking out
of the box or maybe they're their star
person right that's the guy I'm going to
hire you know out of their competency
became promote out of their competency
because they they created this thing
sort of on the side and it was a big
success right everyone knows who these
people are it's hard for leadership to
find them but if you go and talk talk on
the ground everyone knows yo you want to
touch a so and so and so we made an
entire system that was optimized to that
to leverage those people and what
happened was we found that most of our
customers did not believe those people
existed and we couldn't convince them
that those people existed we couldn't
they couldn't even begin to get
comfortable with the idea of empowering
those people to actually go ahead and
create a better workflow for themselves
you know they really believed in that
that really top heavy let's get all the
requirements let's get you know I in the
CEO and the CEO involved they will have
a big committee right and so to design
one little thing became three years long
right and so we couldn't we couldn't get
you know we couldn't actually get people
to deploy it and use it the way that we
had spoken about but on the other hand
we did deploy it at the place where the
system was born and we had all the
success that we had was because we
infected do exactly that we just enabled
what was functionally a tool set to let
people say I want this [ __ ] and I want
that comment with this comment I want
that [ __ ] and I want to order them this
way and I want them this wide and I want
I don't want the column that says like
you know that the date of birth i want
the combat says the agent and the
ability to create new ones on the fly
and make that really really easy to say
only show me the patients that have been
here for too long or only show me that
right and to make their own work lists
was incredibly powerful so the answer is
yes I've thought of it yes I think it's
awesome yes I built an entire product
around it and it was really really
successful until we got it to the hands
of the broader populace who sort of
freaked out when they said we're not
comfortable letting real people do this
but in fact it's it's that attitude that
is the reason why so many places are
having so much difficulty in getting to
success couple of slides that van show
for the dangerous abbreviations in the
triple-a that particular interface right
there is all configurable so Dan's
background is health of health
information systems h.i.m he's not a
programmer but he created all of those
layouts so that interface we purposely
designed that way so that you can change
the displays and and to allow someone
who's not an engineer not technical to
go in and kind of write queries against
the the NLP to answer those questions
themselves so an understanding that to
dr. handlers point the majority of
people are going to want you to give
that to them and they'll click the
button and
run the numbers right but there is that
small subset out there that want to do
it for themselves and they want to say
we know what great you're showing me
trip away but I want to know about
something else so that gives them the
ability to go in there and do it as well
so I agree it's really important that
was what attracted me to to go to a moto
as I saw what we were doing and I said
same idea now with with unstructured
data and it was really fascinating and
really awesome and so I agree very very
powerful concept and the key is having
the guts to let you know actually
leverage that you have to believe in if
you don't believe in crowdsourcing then
you won't believe in this if you believe
in crowdsourcing what you should because
like so much of the world runs on that
now that you know you can get some
really amazing things done
speakers